on va terminer ce journal d'une manière
plus terre à terre vacances oblige
quelles sont les préoccupations
principales des Français lors de cette
période estivale réponse dans un récent
sondage la drague et quel est le lieu le
plus propice pour les rapprochements
amoureux la plage en censé tout de suite
le détail avec l'analyse très poussé de
Jean-Bernard Vitiello
[Musique]
qu'il soit jeune ou qu'il soit vieux les
ou beaux mais aussi maigre ou un petit
peu trop gros les Français en tout cas
drague un max pendant l'été à 80% ils
avouent volontiers profité de la période
des vacances pour tenter une aventure
amoureuse la plage sous un soleil
torride arrive en première position des
lieux où les juilletistes et haoussiens
ont le plus envie de faire l'amour une
belle serveuse de restaurant ou une
starlette sur la Croisette reste le
fantasme favorit des hommes un moniteur
de ski nautique ou de planche à voile
celui des femmes selon plus d'un sondé
sur deux en tout cas la baignade le
pédalo ou encore le bateau sont aussi
des endroits idéaux pour se rencontrer
de près mais alors de très près en fait
tous les lieux où les gens montrent
leurs corps deviennent des lieux
d'incitation au plaisir toute génération
confondues même si parfois c'est vrai
certains le reconnaissent émet n'est
plus de leur âge il faut savoir qu'il y
a la drague de jour à s'écouler
langoureuses mais changement de rythme
dès que mince à la drague de nuit là
pour les corps et les coeurs à prendre
les boîtes deviennent le passage obligé
surtout pour les jeunes et dans ce
contexte 62% des hommes et des femmes
exigent de leur partenaire d'un soir un
préservatif beaucoup n'ont pas forcément
envie de ramener un souvenir de vacances
[Musique]